on est à cinq jours du scrutin comment
vous sentez vous ce soir serein ce
qu'ils veulent les gens sympas trois
valises et toi tu vas solférino après
gatignon ciro pinto placement d'un
tailleur qui m'ont emmené à tout pour
aider les jours est ce qu'il y à un
châle moyens pour qu'on puisse remonter
les souvenirs impossible notre amitié
avec philips et notre faiblesse
fabien vet france alors il ya tout le
désigne comme mon successeur aujourd'hui
tu veux même public comme député je
resterai corde et un dissident mais tôt
ou tard je me passe ailleurs dans le
monde
ils vont tous se liguer contre moi la
parade se défaire pas avec les fachos
qui compte répond filature intimidations
qui comporte il tue ses ficelles
c'est tout ce que tu es censé combattre
en politique l'amitié est votre pire
ennemi
kan s'était passé en france suite à la
nouvelle série événement création
originale de canal+ baron noir en
exclusivité